bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat dans un instant vous
allez pouvoir suivre en direct sur notre
antenne l'examen d'une proposition de
loi sénatoriale qui vise à moderniser le
droit de la chasse à mes côtés pour en
parler le sénateur ladislas poniatowski
rapporteur de ce texte ici au sénat
bonjour alors pourquoi faut-il nouvelle
loi sur la chasse alors que la dernière
date de 2008 c'est-à-dire il ya trois
ans seulement nouvelle oui ça fait un
peu beaucoup pour certains mais en fait
c'est parce que nous tirons les leçons
de ce qui s'est passé depuis la dernière
doit chasse qui a menti ya même pas
trois ans à la fois il ya des erreurs
techniques à la fois nous nous sommes
aperçus qu'il y avait des j'oublie et
c'est une toute petite loin qui n'a que
huit articles et qui a pour objet de
remédier à certaines petites erreurs
seulement c'est dire quelles sont elles
alors dans les oublie il y avait une
chose importante ça concerne les zones
humides paul nous avons toujours été
soucieux au célèbre de défendre les
zones humides qu'il faut protéger en
france et pour une raison très
surprenante des zones humides dans
lesquels on chasse ne pouvait pas
bénéficier des mesures fiscales
avantageuses donc douleur ajoute au
premier exemple autre exemple un nouveau
chasseur qu'il soit jeune ou pas qui
passait son permis on a décidé dans la
dernière loi chance de lui permettre de
payer simplement une demie cotisations
ou une demi redevance or la mesure ne
pouvait pas s'appliquer le jour de son
permis de chasse le jour où le passé
mais que l'année suivante
donc on a réglé ce problème il peut
alors les choses nouvelles que nous
avions oublié très importante
c'est ce qu'on appelle les tous les
territoires en ak aq à ce sont les il ya
des associations communales c'est plus
la moitié de la france et il y avait
deux problèmes réels que cette loi le
mairie de régler le premier c'est que on
permet à deux hakas de cesse de
fusionner elle n'avait pas dans le faire
en d accaparer l'attention de montagne
ce sont des crocs territoire vous avez
de moins en moins de chasseurs est sûre
vous réguliers sur ce territoire il faut
leur parler de fusionner
deuxième particularité un nouveau
propriétaire qui achetait un territoire
en aka n'avez pas le droit de chasser
sur ce territoire
parce qu'ils étaient en dessous d'un
seuil de 21 à 40 états nous permettons à
nouveaux chasseurs de rennes avant de
pouvoir chasser danser à g vous pensez
que parmi toutes ces mesures
certaines vont permettre d'enrayer la
baisse du nombre de chasseurs en france
non je ne pense pas je ne pense pas mais
il ya une petite mesure concrète qui va
certainement et qui était un petit clin
d'oeil aux chasseurs nous allons
permettre demain à tous chasseurs qui
passe son permis dans un département
d'avoir le droit de chasser un jour
supplémentaire dans un autre département
il leur demandera l'autorisation sa
fédération qui la donnera
automatiquement puisque la loi le
prévoit
ce ce sont ce genre de mesures qui vont
je dirais inciter plus facilement un
chasseur de garder son permis il ya
également la délicate question du droit
en fait pour tout propriétaire d'un
terrain de s'opposer à la chasse sur son
territoire certaines associations
s'inquiètent d'une remise en cause de ce
gratte qu'elles ont raison de
s'inquiéter
vous avez raison parce que un des
éléments clés de cette de se taire de ce
texte c'est de permettre dorénavant de
régler le problème des territoires non
chassés
il ya pas loin de 600 territoire en
france qu'ils soient particuliers ou qui
appartiennent à des communes ou qui
appartiennent à l'état des terrains
militaires qui ne sont pas chassés
qu'est ce qui se passe dans ces
territoires
eh bien le gibier s'y concentrent les
sangliers s'est concentré et c'est même
sangliers qui sont protégés dans ces
sites vont ensuite faire des dégâts que
le saut dans les champs de maïs par
exemple ça pleut ce texte prévoit bien
de d'exiger de ce propriétaire qu'ils
soient privés ou publics soit à ce qu'on
procède à des chasses de régulation pour
diminuer la densité du gibier soit à ce
qu' ils paient une indemnité il n'y a
pas de raison que ce soit des chasseurs
des je dirais territoires périphériques
à ces zones qui paie les dégâts
du gibier qui est concentré dans ces
zones mais en aucun cas ça ne retire ce
que vous évoquez c'est à dire le droit
de ne pas exercer la chasse tel que le
prévoit la loi que nous avions adopté il
ya déjà six ans les associations n'ont
pas de raison de s'inquiéter aucune
raison de s'inquiéter
je ne sais pas d'où est venu ce chiffon
rouge qui est agitée il n'y a pas de
crainte
on n'y touche pas merci ladislas
poniatowski d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je vous laisse tout de suite
regagné l'hémicycle du sénat pour suivre
donc l'examen de cette proposition de
loi qui vise à moderniser le droit de la
chasse très bonne séance à tous la
séance s'est reprise bienvenue et madame
le ministre lors du jeu rappelle à dix
questions de la proposition de loi
visant à moderniser le droit de la
chasse présenté par notre collègue
pierre martin dans la discussion
générale qui s'ouvre la parole est donc
maintenant à monsieur pierre martin qui
est auteur de la proposition de loi
sur pierre martins nourry
la parole sera ensuite aux rapporteurs
monsieur loyal et franc
le président adam le ministre mes chers
collègues il y à déjà plus d'un an le 15
mars 2010 je déposé sur le bureau de
notre haute assemblée une proposition de
loi que j'ai aujourd'hui l'honneur de
vous présenter
je suis très heureux que vous en doutez
que ce texte puisse enfin être examiné
cette proposition de loi comporte huit
articles et vise d'une part à promouvoir
une gestion plus efficace de la
biodiversité et d'autre part à
moderniser la législation pour permettre
aux chasseurs de mieux accomplir leur
mission d'intérêt général
lorsque je déposais cette proposition
mes chers collègues
l'année 2010 avait été consacrée année
de la biodiversité
justement émettait alors apparu
nécessaire de rappeler la contribution
de la chasse à la gestion des espèces et
des espaces
quelles que soient nos sensibilités au
sein de cet hémicycle
je crois que nous avons tous à coeur le
souci d'une gestion équilibrée des
espaces naturels et d'une
responsabilisation toujours plus grande
de l'ensemble des acteurs intervenant
dans la préservation de la biodiversité
avant de détailler le texte qui soumis à
notre examen aujourd'hui je voudrais
rappeler les conditions dans lesquelles
ce dernier a été d'abord le premier
élément sur lequel je voudrais insister
et la diminution croissante du nombre de
chasseurs
il a été divisé par deux en moins de 30
ans si la france reste le premier pays
de chasseurs en europe devant l'espagne
et l'italie
elle a toutefois vu le nombre de
pratiquants passé de 2,4 millions au
milieu des années 1970 environ 1,3
million en 2008
cet élément doit être prise en compte
pour rénover la pratique de la sas il
est impératif de trouver les moyens de
la rendre plus attractive et plus
accessible aux jeunes notamment par
ailleurs deuxième élément
de ce contexte les deux années qui ont
suivi l'entrée en vigueur de la dernière
loi relative à la chasse en 2008 la loi
poniatowski ont permis de mettre en
lumière certaines insuffisances en
matière de pratique de la chasse
certains une adaptation des dispositions
en vigueur faiblesses auxquelles nous
pouvons aujourd'hui remédier je suis
intimement persuadé que le législateur
doit avoir une approche pragmatique avec
un souci constant d'améliorer des
dispositifs qui une fois entré en
application sur le terrain font
apparaître un certain nombre de
difficultés
nous sommes des élus locaux nous devons
être attentifs à la bonne application
des normes générales sur nos territoires
c'est dans cet esprit que j'ai entrepris
notamment en tant que président du
groupe d'études chasse au sénat
d'apporter des réponses aux difficultés
rencontrées sur le terrain par les
chasseurs ma démarche a privilégié la
concertation
j'insiste sur ce point car il me semble
absolument indispensable sur un sujet
comme la chasse de consulter l'ensemble
des acteurs concernés et de recueillir
leurs observations concrètes pour faire
avancer les choses dans le bon sens sans
éveiller de polémiques inutiles et
surtout contre productive j'ai donc
travaillé que les chasseurs les
associations communales de chasse
agréées
l'office national de la chasse et de la
faune sauvage et l'ensemble des acteurs
contribuant sur le terrain à une gestion
équilibrée de la biodiversité
le texte issu de ce long travail de
concertation ne révolutionne pas
l'exercice de la chasse il n'en a pas
l'ambition
ils prêtent pas au contraire contribuer
modestement mais efficacement à une
amélioration de sa pratique et à une
mise en valeur du rôle des chasseurs en
matière de biodiversité
c'est un texte court précis et
pragmatique il n'entend rallumer aucune
polémique ni revenir sur des équilibres
à qui il vise simplement
adapter ce droit séculaire qu'est le
droit cynégétique aux évolutions
contemporaines à le simplifier
pour permettre une pratique de la chasse
démocratique apaisée et responsable
venons en maintenant aux détails de la
proposition de loi c 8 arctique
s'articule autour de trois objectifs
principaux
premier objectif une gestion plus
efficace de la biodiversité qui
reconnaît le rôle essentiel des
chasseurs notamment dans la préservation
et la gestion des zones humides
deuxième objectif un meilleur
fonctionnement institutionnel par le
biais d'une réforme des modalités
d'adhésion aux associations communales
de chasse agréées
confronté à une baisse constante de
leurs mômes qui pourrait poser le
problème de pans entiers de territoire
laissé privées de gestion cynégétique
troisième objectif enfin plus complet et
pragmatique une poursuite de la
simplification du droit de la chasse sur
les huit articles initiaux seul un
article a été supprimée en commission de
l'économie a laissé à l'initiative du
rapporteur monsieur ladislas poniatowski
que je félicite et que je remercie
il s'agissait de l'article 8 qui
prévoyait que le gouvernement remette un
rapport au parlement sur les modalités
que pourrait prendre un suivi des
exactions commises en matière d'
obstruction des activités de chasse par
l'observatoire national de la
délinquance et des réponses pénales
le gouvernement s'était fortement
engagée devant notre assemblée en 2008 à
prendre un décret créant un délit d'
entrave à la chasse afin de pouvoir
apporter une réponse juridique à cette
difficulté au moment où j'ai rédigé cet
article
il n'avait toujours pas publié ce décret
ce qui est chose faite depuis avec la
parution du décret du 4 juin 2010 dont
je me réjouis tout en espérant qu'il
fasse l'objet d'une application sans
complaisance c'est donc avec mon
approbation que le rapporteur a proposé
de supprimer cet article devenus
inutiles dans la forme même si les
exactions commises par les extrémistes
des droits de l'animal n'ont pas cessé
en dehors du cadre de la chasse un
article additionnel
a également été introduit lors du
passage en commission il s'agit d'une
simple précision à laquelle je suis
totalement favorable à l'article l 141 1
du code de l'environnement qui ne
mentionnait pas explicitement les
fédération régionale et
interdépartementale de chasseurs au
titre de l'éligibilité à l'agrément de
protection de l'environnement alors que
c'était le cas de la fédération
nationale et des fédérations
départementales
quant aux autres articles je me réjouis
aujourd'hui que l'esprit et les
objectifs qui étaient les leurs dans ma
proposition initiale est été préservé je
dirais même conforté par la commission
de l'isiq de l'économie les articles 1
et 3 vise à reconnaître le rôle
essentiel des chasseurs en matière de
préservation de la biodiversité à ce
sujet j'insiste sur le rôle éminent joué
par les fédérations en matière
d'information d'éducation au
développement durable en matière de
connaissance et de préservation de la
faune sauvage
c'est un fait sur le terrain en 2010 80
fédérations départementales et
régionales ont été sollicités localement
sur l'éducation à l'environnement
l'article 2 relatif à l'exonération de
taxe foncière sur les propriétés non
bâties situées en zones humides a été
précisé pour davantage d'effectivité
pratique et je m'en réjouis
l'objectif demeure il s'agit de garantir
effectivement sur le terrain la
possibilité pour les installations de
chasse situé dans une zone humide kiptum
gabions ut de bénéficier de
l'exonération partielle de taxe foncière
sur la sur les propriétés non bâties la
tfnb au contraire sur le terrain
aujourd'hui
ces dernières en sont a priori exclue au
motif que le simple fait que l'on petit
chasser serait incompatible avec
engagement de préservation de la vie
phone qui fait figure de condition
essentielle pour pouvoir en bénéficier
cet article chers collègues et je crois
très important
il répond à une réelle demande de la
part des chasseurs qui
dans de nombreux départements comme vous
le savez sûrement ont été des
précurseurs dans l'entretien et la
restauration des zones humides penser
aux plats tiers du nord de la france
omar et de la charente ou du médoc ou
encore aux lacunes des landes
ce serait assurément un signal très fort
et positif envoyé aux chasseurs afin de
les inciter à préserver ces zones
humides aujourd'hui menacée et dont on
constate pourtant quel point elles
constituent des lieux privilégiés de
préservation de la biodiversité en
général et pas seulement de la faune
chassables il faut insister sur ce point
l'article 4 quant à lui propose de
régler enfin la question de
l'accumulation du grand gibier dans les
territoires non chassés ou celui ci se
réfugie et quand un flux et qu ensuite
des dégâts matériels dans les champs
voisins
outre les dégâts agricoles la commission
de l'économie a fort justement relevé
lors de cet examen que cette
accumulation cause également de nombreux
accidents de circulation le préfet
pourra ainsi imposé sur la proposition
de la fédération départementale ou
interdépartementale des chasseurs le
prélèvement d'un nombre déterminé
d'animaux un propriétaire d'un
territoire qui ne procèdent pas ou ne
fait pas procéder à la régulation des
espèces sur son front lorsque ces
dernières cause des dégâts si le
prélèvement n'est pas fait la
responsabilité financière du
propriétaire pourra être engagée il
n'est pas possible de continuer à
laisser les fédérations supporter seule
le poids financier de la démonisation
des dégâts je suis en accord par
ailleurs quelques remplacements
sémantique de la notion de plan de tir
par celle de prélèvement d'un nombre
déterminé d'animaux que la commission de
l'économie a opéré ce problème récurrent
est très important je le rappelle les
dégâts financiers et humains causés par
cette accumulation de gibier peuvent
être considérables mais je tiens
également être tout à fait clair cette
mesure ne remet nullement en cause
le droit à l'opposition cynégétique
puisque le propriétaire peut refuser
d'exécuter ou de faire exécuter son
fondement
seulement si c'est le cas le
propriétaire est tenu d'assumer sa
responsabilité environnementale et
d'indemniser les dégâts agricoles commis
par les animaux provenant de son faux
les articles 5 et 6 quant à eux
permettent une meilleure organisation
institutionnelle des associations
communales de chasse agréées qu'on
appelle les actes à l'article 5 autorise
leur fusion en une seule association
intercommunale et l'article 6 assoupli
les modalités d'adhésion
dans le cas de l'acquisition d'une
propriété ou d'une fraction de propriété
et l'enseignant l'objet d'un apport à la
date de création de la cac dans le cas
où l'acquisition porte sur la totalité
de ce territoire
le nouveau propriétaire sera membre de
droit de la quasi le demande dans le cas
où ce dernier et acquéreurs que d'une
fraction de ce même territoire
il ne sera automatiquement membre de
droit que si cette portion est supérieur
au seuil d'opposition en vigueur dans le
département dans le cas contraire les
modalités de son éventuelle adhésion est
déterminée par le règlement intérieur de
la cac cette solution qui va un peu plus
loin que ce que j'avais proposée
initialement est très satisfaisant
d'autant qu'elles émanent des acca
elle-même ces dernières se sont saisis
et il faut s'en réjouir de ce problème
de la baisse du nombre d'adhérents
faisant ainsi preuve de leur capacité à
s'adapter pour garantir une bonne
gestion cynégétique dans la durée
l'article sincère enfin améliore la
rédaction du dispositif introduit par la
loi de 2008 sur la réfaction appliqué à
la redevance cynégétique pour les
nouveaux chasseurs en août à nice il à
l'initiative d'un collègue monsieur rémy
pointereau la commission de l'économie a
introduit à cet article la possibilité
pour un chasseur détenteur d'un permis
départementale validé pour un an
d'obtenir une validation de un jour
valable dans un autre département
cette mesure réclamée par les jeunes
chasseurs notamment vaud
le sens d'une plus grande activité de la
pratique de la chasse et j'y suis
personnellement favorable dans son
principe
sous réserve de prévoir un encadrement
du dispositif en effet éviter le
nomadisme des chasseurs et pour mettre
une organisation rationnelle de la
délivrance de ces validations il faudra
déterminer précisément quelle fédération
là des livres
s'agit-il de la fédération d'origine ou
de la fédération d'accueil selon quelles
modalités
et c'est au total je juge cet ajout
sympathique mais assez difficilement
applicable il y avait déjà le permis
deux jours et le permis trois jours
nous inventons aujourd'hui le permis à
jour sans en avoir mesuré toutes les
implications
voilà rapidement brossé mes chers
collègues le détail de la proposition de
loi que je suis heureux de voir arriver
en discussion devant vous aujourd'hui
elle ne transformera pas en profondeur
le droit de la chasse elle n'y a pas
vocation mais par petites touches
elle s'attache atteinte de plus près
l'objectif énoncé par victor sherer dans
son rapport réinventer la chasse du 21e
siècle pour le conseil économique et
social la chasse réinventer pour le 21e
siècle contribue à la restauration de la
qualité écologique des territoires
ruraux et au rétablissement des liens
sociaux harmonieux cet objectif doit
être toujours aujourd'hui le nôtre c'est
pourquoi je souhaite remercier collègues
que vous exprimiez un vote identique à
celui qui a mis la commission
d'économies afin de démontrer une fois
de plus que le sénat est une pré force
de proposition d'adaptation et de
modernisation aujourd'hui au servir de
au service de la chasse et du monde
rural
merci monsieur pierre martin dans la
suite de la discussion maintenant la
parole est aux rapporteurs de la
commission de l'économie
monsieur ladislas poniatowski
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues le 13 avril
dernier la commission de l'économie du
développement durable et d'aménagement
du territoire a adopté à l'unanimité des
présents
la proposition de loi visant à
moderniser le droit de la chasse de
notre collègue pierre martin que je me
réjouis de voir de retour dans notre
hémicycle
après une interruption de quelques
longues semaines pour des raisons de
santé que je vois d'attac
non pas pour chasser mais pour défendre
sa loi sur la chasse proposition qu'il a
déposé le 15 mars 2010 et que nous avons
adoptée en y apportant quelques
modifications
en tout premier lieu je tiens à saluer
le travail de notre collègue pierre
martial féliciter d'avoir été à
l'initiative d'un texte qui comme il
vient de nous l'exposé vise d'une part à
rappeler le rôle essentiel des chasseurs
dans la préservation de la biodiversité
et d'autre part de manière plus concrète
à améliorer la pratique de la chasse
ce texte élaboré un peu plus d'un an
après la dernière loi relative à la
chasse du 31 décembre 2008 dont j'étais
à l'origine constitue le sixième texte
relatif à la chasse en un peu plus de
dix ans et est il vraiment utile
ma réponse est clairement oui car le
monde de la chasse est confronté à un
double contexte que vous connaissez tous
mes chers collègues et que vient de
rappeler un peu pierre martin
premièrement c'est le contexte d'une
diminution constante du nombre de
chasseurs qui a été divisé de moitié en
appel les générations les pratiquants
sont en effet moins d'un million 3
aujourd'hui alors qu'ils étaient le
double dans les années 1970 il n'y a
qu'un seul moyen d'agir face à cela il
faut rendre la chasse toujours plus
accessible et toujours plus attractive
deuxième élément de contexte qui est
inextricablement lié au premier
l'évolution du rôle et de la place du
chasseur en tant qu'acteur de la
préservation de la biodiversité des
états généraux de la chasse
se sont tenues à paris en février
dernier nous étions d'ailleurs
quelques-uns ici présents ils ont été
l'occasion de débattre du rôle de la
place de la chasse dans la société
d'aujourd'hui et de demain analyse en
toute logique d'évolutions majeures qui
a caractérisé le début du xxième siècle
d'émergence du concept même de la
biodiversité
madame la ministre je peux vous dire que
votre intervention il a été d'ailleurs
très apprécié au cours de ces dernières
années des acteurs concernés sont
parvenus à trouver un équilibre agro
sylvo cynégétique qui s'est traduit par
une volonté de protéger et restaurer les
zones humides d'indemniser les dégâts de
gibier et enfin d'améliorer moderniser
la gestion de la pratique de la chasse
ce serait une erreur de le remettre en
cause dans ce double contexte ce texte
court et efficace a le mérite de
remédier aux insuffisances de la
législation en vigueur et de conforter
le rôle des chasseurs
deux précisions mais d'examiner ce texte
premièrement l'élaboration de ce texte a
fait l'objet
mon cher pierre martin d'une vraie
concertation en amont et j'ai eu en tant
que rapporteur l'occasion de me rendre
compte au fil de la vingtaine
d'auditions que j'ai effectués
deuxièmement vous savez sans doute peu
chers collègues et donc je ne m'étendrai
pas l'assemblée nationale 1 ce qui à son
tour bus à son ordre du jour une
proposition de loi déposée près d'un an
après celle de notre collègue et qui
reprend l'essentiel de ces dispositions
inutile de dire que ce procédé n'est pas
forcément très élégant mais il ne doit
pas nous empêcher d'examiner sereinement
et sérieusement notre texte
notre collègue pierre martin on a très
bien exposé les enjeux a très bien
exposé les enjeux de sa proposition de
loi donc je serai rapide et me
concentrerai sur les modifications que
nous avons apportées en commission la
proposition de loi initial comportait
huit arctique
elle en comporte toujours 8 mai a été
supprimé un autre a été rajoutée à mon
initiative la commission d'économie a
étendu le champ d'application de
l'article 1er
au fédération régionale des chasseurs en
effet ces dernières même au même titre
que les fédérations départementales et
interdépartementale des actions
d'information et de sensibilisation en
matière d'environnement
il est donc nécessaire de l'inscrire
dans le code de l'environnement
la commission a également adopté à
l'unanimité une nouvelle rédaction de
l'article 2 visant à faire bénéficier
les installations de chasse situé en
zone humide de l'exonération partielle
de taxe foncière sur les propriétés non
bâties prévues par le code général des
impôts afin d'inciter à la préservation
des zones humides en effet aujourd'hui
ces territoires ne peuvent voler
bénéficier par principe dans la mesure
où la condition de préservation de
l'avifaune est réputé incompatibles avec
la pratique de la chasse
ce qui est surprenant l'article 2 tel
qu'il a été rédigé par la commission
précise donc clairement que cet
engagement de gestion n'exclut pas par
principe la pratique de la chasse
l'article 3 je m'y attends tu as bien je
ne m'y attends pas bien été précisée par
notre auteur du texte de loi remplace la
notion d'écosystème parcelle de
biodiversité
il a été adopté sans modification
l'article 4 traite d'un sujet
particulièrement important et je
voudrais me arrêté un instant il existe
en france 700 à 800 territoires non
chassés territoires privés et publics
communaux et des territoires ddt et a
parfois des territoires importants car
ce sont des terrains militaires
ces zones pose le problème soulevé
depuis plusieurs années déjà par les
dégâts provoqués par le gibier qui s'y
accumulent c'est des gars représente
environ un million et demi d'euros à la
charge des fédérations départementales
soit 5 % de la facture annuelle en outre
de gibier qui s'accumulent sur ces
territoires manches à ses causes non
seulement des dégâts agricoles mais
également des dégâts matériels et
humains en raison des nombreux accidents
qui en découlent comme l'a fort
justement souligné françois patriat
de notre réunion en commission nous
aurons l'occasion d'y revenir lors de la
discussion des articles mais l'article
cap règles ainsi un problème important
en prévoyant que le préfet peut à la
demande de la fédération de chasse
imposer le prélèvement d'un nombre
déterminé d'animaux aux propriétaires de
ces territoires qui ne régule pas ou ne
procède pas à la régulation des animaux
présents sur son territoire et qui
causent des dégâts ou en cas inverse a
exigé une indemnisation financière
l'article 5 apporte de la souplesse au
regroupement des associations communales
de chasse agréées les acca en une seule
association intercommunale
elles ont la possibilité aujourd'hui
mais en gardant chacune sa personnalité
propre
cet article leur permet de fusionner
c'est le souhaitent
quant à l'article 6 qui vise à assouplir
les modalités d'adhésion osaka la
commission de l'économie on a adopté à
l'unanimité une nouvelle rédaction basée
sur une proposition que je qualifierais
de très responsable d'ea qu'à elle même
il s'agit d'éviter les effets néfastes
de la désertification humain de
certaines communes des pans entiers de
territoires pourraient se trouver privés
de toutes formes de gestion cynégétique
bonjour aujourd'hui lorsque vous achetez
un terrain soumis à l'action dinaqua le
droit de chasser et transféré à la cahc
et vous ne pouvez en disposer
le nombre d'amendés à cannes ne cesse
donc de diminuer d'articles prévoir la
nouvelle rédaction de l'article prévoit
deux cas de figure si l'acquéreur achète
l'intégralité de la propriété alors il
reconnu membre de droit de la cac s'il
en fait la demande bien sûr si
l'acquéreur achète une partie de cette
propriété
et si cette faction est supérieure à 10%
chiffres n'ont pas imposé par le
parlement suggérée par les acca elle
même si cette faction est supérieure à
10 % du seuil d'opposition en vigueur
pour le département il est reconnu
membre de droit de la cac et je dirais
cerise sur le gâteau même si c'est une
part inférieure à 10%
le mans interne de l'acca peut permettre
à son milieu l'acquéreur d'en devenir
membre à l'article 7 qui prévoit de
rectifier une erreur matérielle
concernant la réfaction sur la redevance
cynégétique pour les nouveaux chasseurs
la commission de l'économie a introduit
à l'initiative de notre collègue rémy
pointereau cette possibilité évoquée il
ya quelques minutes pour tout détenteur
d'une validation départemental de son
permis de chasse et d'obtenir une
validation de un jour pour un autre
département
c'est un petit coup de clin d'oeil aux
chasseurs pas inutile la chasse se
pratique en grande convivialité et très
souvent on est invités et on renvoie
l'invitation l'invitation est dans un
département voisin
grâce à cette mesure on peut obtenir
pour un jour de chasse l'autorisation
d'aller chasser dans un département
voisin
l'article 8 de la proposition de loi
l'article 8 initial qui prévoyait un
rapport du gouvernement sur les
modalités d'un éventuel suivi par
l'observatoire national de la
délinquance et des réponses pénales des
exactions commises par les extrémistes
lors des chasses a été unanimement
supprimée par la commission en accord
avec pierre martin que j'avais
auditionné par téléphone dans la période
difficile qu'il a traversés dans la
mesure où le décret trvailleurs le délit
d'initié entrave à la chasse à et je les
en remercie madame le ministre a enfin
été publié
et enfin il a été inséré à mon
initiative un article additionnel visant
à combler une lacune à l'article l 141 1
du code de l'environnement en précisant
que lé fédération régionale et
interdépartementale des chasseurs sont
comme les fédérations départementales
éligibles à l'agrément au titre de la
protection de l'environnement
voilà en quelques mots mes chers
collègues
l'essentiel du travail qui a été fait en
commission et des propositions de
modification ou d'entérinement au texte
initial présenté par nos votre collègue
pierre martin
je vous en remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur la parole
est maintenant à madame le ministre de
l'écologie du développement durable des
transports et du logement nathalie
kosciusko morizet adama ministre bonjour
merci monsieur le président ce président
de la commission jean paul monsieur le
rapporteur
monsieur le président du groupe chasse
et auteurs de cette proposition de loi
pierre martin mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs la production législative sur
le sujet de la chasse est dense et au
cours des dix dernières années ce sont
pas moins de cinq lois qui lui ont été
consacrés de loi chasse en 2000 et en
2003 puis la loi sur le développement
des territoires ruraux en 2005 suivie en
2008 d'une nouvelle loi chasse à votre
initiative monsieur le rapporteur
puis enfin en 2009 de mesures à
l'occasion de la loi relative à
l'allègement des procédures
administratives et cette abondance
provale seul l'importance que le
parlement reconnaît à cette activité
une activité à multiples facettes qui
d'un côté contribuer à la gestion de la
biodiversité de l'autre et du même
mouvement les est de première importance
pour les hommes et femmes qui s'y
adonnent et qui sont attachés à travers
elle à leur territoire une activité
enfin majeur du fait de son importance
sociale et de son poids économique
la chasse génère rêve toujours peu
difficile de compter ses chauffeurs mais
l'achat générerait 23 mille emplois et 2
milliards 300 millions d'euros de flux
financiers alors le législateur pourrait
s'inquiéter et le fait en d'autres
occasions de l'abondance législatives
dont je viens de faire étape à ce que
cinq lois en dix ans après tout est-ce
que c'est pas suffisant pour améliorer
le corpus législatif faire en sorte que
les chasseurs puissent exercer leur
passion dans les meilleures conditions
et finalement adapté la chasse française
au dispositif communautaire
et internationaux et pourtant comme l'a
rapporté le sénateur martin à l'origine
de cette proposition loi la chasse est
une activité vivante et s'il ne s'agit
pas aujourd'hui de révolutionner le
droit de la chasse il y en a pas moins
un certain nombre d'adaptations
intéressantes et importantes qui peuvent
lui être apportées et notamment pour
tenir compte du souhait a cru que nous
avons tous de préserver notre
environnement
je voudrais tout d'abord souligner
l'intérêt qui a selon moi ça n'est pas
que symbolique ça n'est pas que
déclaratoire a rappelé que les chasseurs
sont des acteurs et des défenseurs de la
biodiversité je le disais ça a été
soulignée par votre rapporteur lors des
états généraux de la chasse le 16
février dernier je crois que ça devait
être mieux explicités parce que c'est
quelque chose qui est évident pour les
acteurs du monde de la chasse qui n'est
pas forcément pour tout ce monde de la
chasse est pas forcément bien bien
connue de tous et c'était l'occasion de
reconnaître l'action de toutes les
fédérations de chasseurs en faveur de la
conservation de la biodiversité y
compris les fédération régionale et
interdépartementale
c'est le sens des articles 1 3 et 8 bis
de la présente proposition loi ce
dernier a été rajouté en commission à
l'initiative du rapporteur
je crois que cette démarche va dans le
bon sens et c'est aussi la raison pour
laquelle j'ai signé le 3 mars dernier
l'arrêté qui accorde à la fnc son
d'agrément comme associations de
protection de l'environnement
l'article 2 qui est relatif à
l'exonération de la taxe foncière pour
les territoires aménagé pour la chasse
en zone humide poursuit le même objectif
permettez moi de m'arrêter un peu sur
cet article parce que c'est un peu
technique mais ça mérite d'être
explicite et la loi de 2005 visait
plutôt à soutenir les terrains humides
qui ne bénéficient pas de rémunération
conséquente comme par exemple les
prairies humides alors que les milieux
humides qui sont chassés tonnes gabions
ut peuvent bénéficier de tarifs de
location est levé il ya donc un revenu
mais pour autant il n'était pas dans
l'esprit de la loi de 1905 déc
klur ces terrains de l'exonération de
tfnb y avait peut-être ici forme
d'ambiguïté
en tout cas le fait que ça n'était pas
dans l'esprit de la loi 2005 d'exclure
ces terrains a été confirmée par mon
prédécesseur à votre rapporteur en
réponse à une question écrite en 2009
pourtant je considère que ces milieux
parmi les plus menacés souvent parmi les
plus dégradés en france aussi parce
qu'ils sont parmi les plus fragiles
peuvent utilement y accueillir les
chasseurs qui joue un rôle important en
terme de protection d'entretien parfois
de restauration et il convient
d'encourager leurs pratiques dans ce
sens c'est l'objet de cet article que je
soutiendrai avec toutefois un amendement
de précision que je je vous soumettrai
par ailleurs il faut faciliter le
fonctionnement institutionnel tout
autant que l'accueil des nouveaux
chasseurs l'importance de ce mouvement a
été soulignée par le sénateur martin
dans un contexte de diminution constante
du nombre de chasseurs il faut être ici
cohérent si on considère et c'est le cas
que les chasseurs participent d'une
forme de protection de la biodiversité
la diminution du nombre de chasseurs en
france le risque à terme de disparition
de cette activité est un problème et
c'est un problème que nous voulons
combattre le monde cynégétique en milieu
rural a beaucoup évolué et il faut
répondre à cette évolution chercher de
nouvelles dynamiques les propositions
relatives au fonctionnement des
associations communales de chasse
agréées proposés ceux ci aux articles 5
et 6 vont dans ce sens et puis la
présente proposition noir ont également
opérationnels dans son article 7
une disposition qui avait déjà été
adopté par la loi chasse en 2008 pour
diminuer le coût du permis pour les
jeunes chasseurs
je suis en revanche plus réservé je le
dis ici sur la joue à cet article de la
validation du permis pour un jour je
crois que ni la fnc ni le ffs ne sont
demandeurs de cette disposition
elle risque d'être administrativement
plutôt compliquée à mettre en oeuvre et
il existe par ailleurs déjà la
validation pour trois jours à un coût
très accessible pour les jeunes
chasseurs
il me semble donc qu'elle est
superfétatoire
enfin qu'un martin comme l'a dit ça ce
fait hausse qui ont tous les deux
souligné la question malheureusement
récurrente de l'indemnisation de dégâts
de gibier je souhaite à ce propos vous
proposer un amendement à l'article 4 qui
traite à juste raison de cette question
en complétant la responsabilité qui est
déjà inscrite dans la loi du titulaire
d'un plan de chasse et d'une personne
ayant marqué son opposition à la chasse
par la responsabilité du détenteur du
droit de chasse qui ne savent pas ce
sera plus facile après cela de faire
appel à sa responsabilité financière
parce qu'il est effectivement injuste
que les fédérations de chasse soit
responsable financièrement de dégâts
d'animaux qui prospère sur des terrains
qui sont non chauffés enfin sur le
rapporteur sur le sénateur martin vous
avez souligné la suppression en
commission de l'article 8
je pense qu'il s'agissait d'un article
d'appel auxquelles le gouvernement a
répondu par ailleurs en publiant le
décret du 4 juin dernier sur
l'obstruction à la chasse et je tiens à
souligner ici que cette publication a
été efficace puisque les chasses à
courre qui était principales victimes de
ces mouvements souffrait d'une dizaine
d'actes d'obstruction à la chasse il y a
trois en ont été victimes
la dernière saison que d'une tentative
ce dispositif est donc efficace dames
les messieurs les sénateurs l'ensemble
de ces dispositions nouvelles facilitera
une contribution accrue de la chasse
trois piliers du développement rural
tant il est vrai qu au delà de leur
attachement profond à la nature et leur
contribution à une activité économique
importante
les chasseurs jouent un rôle déterminant
en matière de lien social je vous
remercie
merci madame la ministre dans la suite
de la discussion générale
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
joseph k crise
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mais chers collègues vous l'avez dit
madame à 12h06 un instant on n'a jamais
tant légiférer sur la chasse que ces dix
dernières années
ceci procède d'un certain nombre de
causes qui tiennent à l'évolution de nos
territoires de leur environnement de
leur démographie du système juridique
qui les régissent qui tiennent aussi au
fait que les chasseurs change qu'ils
sont moins nombreux et oblige de ce fait
le droit s'adapter pour favoriser la
pérennité de cette pratique fortement
ancré dans la culture de nos territoires
le texte que nous nous apprêtons à
examiner répond justement et de manière
pragmatique à ce besoin d'adapter le
droit de la chasse à cette évolution
en premier lieu je voudrais souligner
qu'au delà de son aspect social culturel
ou 2d verte' de divertissement la chasse
contribue de manière singulière sur nos
territoires à la gestion des espèces et
à la gestion des espaces naturels qui
les abritent la pratique de cette
dernière année a montré qu'un grand
nombre de conventions ont été passées
pour encadrer les pratiques de chasse
tant du point de vue de son impact sur
l'environnement que du point de vue de
son impact sur la sécurité et ceci je me
plais le constater moi qui ne suis pas
chasseur avec des résultats tout à fait
heureux en termes de sécurité mais aussi
en termes de relations et de
pacification de la relation que les
populations de ceux qui ne sont pas
chasseur et nous pouvons que nous
féliciter que ces bonnes pratiques
ce soit ainsi généralisé chez les
chasseurs en cadres et bien sûr par les
schémas départementaux cynégétique
la proposition de loi aujourd'hui on est
l'aboutissement heureux
je salue donc l'initiative notre
collègue pierre martin de scellés et de
reconnaître dans la loi la
responsabilité des chasseurs dans leur
contribution à l'entretien de
l'environnement et à leur contribution
dans le maintien de la biodiversité pour
entrer dans le détail il nous faut
souligner que depuis quelques années et
notamment l'eau à l'occasion du grenelle
de l'environnement la gestion de la
biodiversité devenu une composante
essentielle du développement durable ce
dont nous nous réjouissons tous cette
biodiversité s'apprécie naturellement en
considérant la diversité des écosystèmes
des espèces des populations dans
l'espace et dans le temps ainsi que leur
organisation et leur répartition
et c'est là que les chasseurs jouent un
rôle indéniable en tant qu ils
permettent de réguler certaines espèces
qui si elles n'étaient pas tirés
pourrait porter atteinte à l'équilibré
des écosystèmes
je pense notamment sangliers bien sûr
cette régulation est encadrée pour
permettre aussi aux espèces de se
reproduire la deuxième forme d'action
des chasseurs pour la préservation de la
biodiversité passe par l'entretien
qu'ils font des zones qu'ils parcourent
et notamment l'évoquions tout à l'heure
des zones humides
la loi doit les encourager dans cette
démarche par une fiscalité non
discriminatoire des installations de
chasse dans les zones humides l'impact
au niveau fiscal en est est en plus peu
déterminants au vu de l'importance de
l'action des chasseurs dans la
préservation de l'entretien de ces zones
cette proposition va donc également dans
le bon sens la troisième disposition que
je souhaite souligner dans le rôle des
chasseurs pour réguler la gestion des
espèces a trait à l'indemnisation que
vous évoquiez précédemment madame la
ministre dans s'agissant des dégâts du
grand gibier dans les territoires non
chassés
aujourd'hui la seule charge des
fédérations départementales des
chasseurs
ce qui ne peut durer l'attribution d'un
plan de tir où je devrais dire plutôt
d'un plan de prélèvement d'un nombre
déterminé d'animaux propriétaires de
terrains non chassés me semble une
dispositions nécessaires et permet de
répartir les responsabilités des dégâts
causés par le gibier de façon plus
équitable
en outre les dispositions du texte qui
affecte directement la communauté des
chasseurs qui connaît malheureusement
une diminution de ses membres vont dans
le bon sens la france a perdu nous ne
savons plus d'un million de chasseurs
entre 74 et 2008 et est donc
indispensable d'adapter les modalités
d'adhésion aux associations de chasse
afin de favoriser les nouvelles
adhésions ou du moins d'en lever les
potentiels obstacle à cette fin il est
indispensable de permet de voir de
suggérer le regroupement au niveau
intercommunal des associations de chasse
communale
ce mouvement va de pair avec la réalité
de l'intercommunale ieg communalisation
si vous me permettez ce terme de nos
territoires ruraux
les associations du ch à son niveau
intercommunal permettent ainsi de
promouvoir le rôle social de
l'intercommunalité
au delà de ses fonctions économique et
d'aménagement du territoire
d'autre part l'automaticité d'adhésion à
la cac pour l'acquéreur d'un terrain
situé sur le territoire de lac est une
évolution qui me semble souhaitable
dès lors qu'elle exclue de ce droit les
microparcelles il s'agit là encore d'une
modernisation attendue du droit de la
chasse l'aurez compris tout ce qui peut
permettre de promouvoir de nouvelles
adhésions de développer ces associations
qui assurent un lien social important
dans nos territoires et sont fortement
inscrite dans la banque hre et pardon
dans la culture populaire est pour ma
part une source de satisfaction
je souhaiterais clore cette brève
intervention en me réjouissant de la
suppression de l'article 8 par la
commission lartigue besnerais d'une
rédaction que l'on comprend avait mes
yeux
dans un texte qui me semblent empreints
d'une belle sérénité
l'inconvénient de raviver des conflits
potentiels
la commission a eu la sagesse de la
supprimer
à l'unanimité des je me rends m'en
réjouis
et ce d'autant plus apte à mlle me
disent que le décret du 10 juin 2010
permet de résoudre les problèmes qui
sont si c'est que sont susceptibles de
poser elle les actions des activistes de
la cause animale
ceci étant et contenu de ce texte
notre groupe de l'union centriste le
votera dans la mesure où il constitue un
tout cohérent
l'aboutissement de pratiques
respectueuses de l'environnement et du
respect des droits de chacun
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à jean louis carrère au nom
du groupe socialiste
ces gens
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
monsieur le président du groupe chasse
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
vous l'avais déjà dit mais de nombreuses
dispositions législatives concernant la
chasse ont été adoptées lors de la
dernière décennie
il s'agissait de projets de loi relative
à la chasse comme la loi de 2000
victoire voynet et la loi de 2003 ou de
projets de lois plus généralistes comme
la loi de développement des territoires
ruraux de 2005
mais vous avez raison ce sont les
parlementaires qui ont été à
l'initiative des dernières évolutions du
droit de la chasse à chaque fois sous
couvert de simplification proposition de
loi numéro 2 169 portée par le sénateur
poniatowski pour l'amélioration et la
simplification du droit de la chasse
adopté conforme à l'assemblée nationale
en décembre 2008 proposition de loi
numéro 1085 de jean luc warsmann de
simplification et de clarification du
droit et d'allègement des procédures
adoptées en avril 2009 cette tendance se
confirme avec la présente proposition de
loi visant à moderniser le droit de la
chasse est présenté depuis plus d'un an
par pierre martin sénateur de la somme
et successeur de ladislas poniatowski à
la présidence du groupe d'études chasse
et pêche du sénat il s'agira donc de la
sixième loi portant sur l'achat 111 ans
et bien évidemment je trouve moi aussi
que ça fait un peu beaucoup même si la
chasse se relève des choses qui
m'intéressent au plus haut point
à noter cependant mes chers collègues qu
une ppl portant diverses dispositions
d'ordre cynégétique a été déposée
récemment à l'assemblée nationale part
de nos collègues
député jérôme bignon aussi élu de la
somme et président du groupe d'études
chasser territoire et plusieurs de ses
collègues elle a été renvoyée à la
commission du développement durable et
de l'aménagement du territoire et
devrait être examiné par l'assemblée le
10 mai donc après l'examen de la ppl
martin au sénat nous y sommes
cette ppl et en plus récentes et
comportant les mêmes articles que la ppl
martin en plus d'une dizaine votre
article on pourrait croire qu'elle s'est
enrichie des propositions élaborées lors
des états généraux de la chasse de
février dernier
mais il semblerait qu'il n'en est rien
cherchez l'erreur
cherchez l'erreur je voudrais brièvement
maintenant vous parler de la table ronde
sur la chasse les différentes tables
rondes qui ont été organisés qui nous
ont un petit peu préoccupé j'avais en
son temps d'ailleurs fait remarquer ici
au sénat lors du débat parlementaire que
j'étais étonné de la représentation
quasi monolithique des formations
politiques constituant le panel à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat au
sein de cette table-ronde nîmes avait
été répondu à l'époque d'ailleurs et
c'est inscrits dans les registres 1 que
j'y serai associé ou que la sensibilité
politique à laquelle j'appartiens
pourraient être représentés
étant entendu qu'il n'est pas interdit
encore en france aux socialistes de
pratiquer la chasse ça pourrait venir
mais mais bon voilà
et j'avais cru comprendre que d'ailleurs
merci j'avais pu bénéficier du soutien
de de beaucoup des collègues siégeant
sur les bancs de la majorité
mais je vous rassure ou plutôt je ne
vous rassure pas il n'en a rien été
il n'en a rien été mais ça a été
beaucoup plus loin m je ne vais pas vous
rappeler les différentes tables rondes
sont au nombre de sept et puis la
dernière qui a eu lieu je vous le donne
en mille
au plein coeur de la campagne des
élections régionales qui n'a concerné
que d'un territoire ou peut-être 3 mais
surtout deux la picardie et les landes
sur les landes je comprends il n'y avait
pas d'espérance de victoire électorale
pour la majorité actuelle
donc comme vous pouvez charger les
landes on pouvait même leur interdire un
certain nombre de pratiques et on
pouvait accorder mais avait-on besoin de
charger les landes pour autoriser des
prélèvements doit tout à fait compatible
avec non seulement la conservation de
l'espèce et avec l'évolution des
populations
c'est ça qui m'a préoccupé mais là j'ai
commencé à comprendre la vilenie qui
consistait à écarter certains d'entre
nous de ces tables rondes il ne faut pas
les chers collègues utiliser des tables
rondes sur la chasse ou d'autres
artifices pour pénaliser des territoires
et en privilégier d'autres je qualifie
cela de basses manoeuvres politiciennes
qui n'ont rien à voir avec l'intérêt
général de la pratique de cet art dans
notre pays qui disqualifie un peu ceux
qui s'y livrent et je pense que au
moment où le sénat et je rends hommage à
mes collègues ont tout fait pour
réhabiliter si tant est qu'elle en avait
besoin
mais pour accréditer l'idée que la
chasse était une pratique responsable
honorable en pleine évolution
de telles pratiques constituent un
handicap pour l'évolution de la
perception de la chasse dans notre pays
et je le regrette
ceci étant dit s'agissant de la
proposition de loi de notre ami
président du groupe chasse elle
correspond tout à fait à la description
qu'il en a fait
avec notre rapporteur elle n'a pas la
prétention de révolutionner ou de
bouleverser
pratique de la chasse en france mais
elle permettra par petites touches de
faire en sorte que cette pratique
s'améliore après une concertation avec
les as et ca
j'appelle ça les a cessé à nous on ne
les appelle pas les a calmés mais c'est
la même chose il s'agit d association
communale de chasse agrée bien
évidemment et aussi avec l'attractivité
que l'on voudrait donner à la pratique
de la chasse auprès des jeunes qui il
faut bien le reconnaître ne viennent pas
la rencontre est de moins en moins
je suis tout à fait conscient comme vous
l'avez exprimé de la diminution
drastique du nombre de chasseurs qui
nous préoccupe qui doit aussi préoccupé
le gouvernement et je vous ai entendu
madame la ministre
pourquoi parce que le service public
liés à la régulation des espèces qui est
fait gratuitement par les chasseurs
d'ailleurs je vais vous en toucher deux
mots tout à l'heure ne sera plus fait
alors qui sera responsable
ce sera le gouvernement qui fera des
battues administratives ça ce sera un
vrai problème
moi je trouve que ce texte de loi est
important malgré tout dans le sens où il
permet aux as et ca de fusionner ou les
choses sont clarifiées où il permet
alors j'étais hésitant monsieur le
rapporteur sur l'idée même et j'étais
assez proche de la position du
gouvernement de la possibilité du permis
d'un jour sachant que le permis de trois
jours était un permis peu coûteux je me
demande s'il n'aurait pas mieux valu le
rendre plus accessible encore et ne pas
modifier pour aller à un jour mais enfin
je pense que là dessus aussi
quand on a vraiment la volonté d'aboutir
on trouvera un accord
je voudrais en profiter madame la
ministre pardonnez moi ce ne sera pas
très long pour indiquer quand même deux
préoccupations majeures à l'occasion du
débat sur ce cette proposition de loi
une position
kim été inspiré par au moins la remontée
à l'interpellation d'une quarantaine de
fédérations de chasseurs en france donc
je tiens la liste à votre dispositions
relatives aux dégâts de gibier il n'est
plus possible compte tenu de l'effet
ciseau qui est en train de s'opérer
d'un côté diminution drastique du nombre
de chasseurs de l'autre côté
accroissement du gros gibier en même
temps accroissement des surfaces
cultivées et évolution du prix des
céréales qui servent de référence au
calcul de l'indemnisation
il n'est plus possible madame la
ministre pour les fédérations qui vivent
de bénévolat et de la cotisation
d'hommes et de femmes aux conditions
modestes de faire face à ce qui se passe
je voudrais en 2000 et vous donner des
éléments très objectif l'indemnisation
des dégâts de grand gibier est
aujourd'hui une question budgétaire
préoccupante pour les fédérations de
chasse le budget des gars est alimentée
uniquement par les recettes du plan de
chasse vente de bracelets et au cas par
cas par un thème ressembliez de plus en
plus deux fédérations sont contrainte
d'appeler en plus une taxe territoriales
pour équilibrer leur budget le fait que
les populations de sangliers augmente de
partout en france ce qui provoque une
augmentation des dégâts
aucun signe ne laisse à penser que les
populations de sangliers retrouveront le
niveau des années 80
parallèlement la population de chasseurs
continue de baisser à un rythme stable
hélas de 2% par an il devient donc
urgent de réfléchir à réformer le
système d'indemnisation des dégâts de
grands viviers faute de quoi madame la
ministre
les fédérations ne pourront plus assumer
cette mission de service public et on
pourrait assister au dépôt de bilan de
certaines fédérations
il n'est pas question de revenir sur le
principe de la loi
par contre il conviendrait de réexaminer
peut-être le décret du 30 août 2006 qui
fixe à 76 euros le seuil
au dessous duquel un exploitant agricole
ne peut prétendre à une indemnisation
équivalent à une franchise
ce sont en moyenne 22 millions d'euros
d'indemnisations parents qui en plus des
frais s'élèvent à plus de 40 millions
d'euros qui sommes déboursées par
l'ensemble des fédérations
l'idée serait de revenir à un système
plus juste et plus en adéquation avec la
réalité
en partant du postulat que la franchise
de 76 euros est anormalement basse
d'autant plus que ce sont les seuls
chasseurs bénévoles qui alimentent cette
caisse ceux qui reviennent à fournir
madame la ministre une assurance
gratuite au monde agricole est loin de
moi l'idée d'engager une polémique où un
conflit entre le monde agricole et le
monde de la chasse
ce sont deux mondes qui vivent
étroitement imbriqués il faut que nous
trouvions une solution
c'est absolument nécessaire il en va de
la survie de nos pratiques et de nos
passions à hautmont sur les dérogations
madame la ministre
sud ouest zoom aquitaine un petit peu
landes
madame la ministre est scandaleux que
des chasseurs vous demande une étude
scientifique pour mesurer l'évolution de
certaines espèces est scandaleux que ces
chasseurs puissent vous dire comme moi
cette tribune en tant que parlementaire
que le président du conseil régional
d'aquitaine et que le président du
conseil général des landes participeront
au financement des frais de cette étude
que la seule condition c'est que cette
étude décidé par vous puis se choisir
les experts à votre convenance et que
nous en choisirons pour que cette étude
soit parfaitement un élan mais il faut
qu'elle soit acceptée
vous savez madame la ministre fait
revoter 800 chasseurs à main levée pour
l'assistance somme définitive de
pratique qu'à paris on des clair et
lucide qui se dit ni citerne ou à
bruxelles nommé
venez avec moi
vivre cela et vous verrez que quelle est
leur courtoisie mais la difficulté que
nous avons rencontrée et admettre qu'ils
arrêtent complètement ces pratiques s'il
ya danger pour une espèce je pense que
c'est une grande évolution parce que ce
que nous contestons madame la ministre
nous contestons simplement l'origine des
chiffrages qui permettent aux uns et aux
autres de nous dire que ces populations
sont en diminution est en danger nous
avons même des raisons scientifiques de
le contester
mais nous aimerions le confronter par la
méthode des isotopes et nous sommes en
mesure de prouver
oui madame lemieux voyez vous ne le
savez pas que les populations qui sont
chassés le correspondent pas aux
populations en danger
donc moi je ne vous demande pas je ne
vous demande pas de choses
extraordinaires
je vous demande simplement s'agissant de
l'oiseau qui s'appelle le pen sommet de
notre oiseau qui s'appelle le bruyant
que nous ayons des études et que nous
régulions ce problème au mieux
juste un mot madame la ministre sur la
chasse et ses représentants en france
j'ai beaucoup d'estimé et quelquefois
même une certaine confiance dans les
défenseurs de la chasse sur tous les
bancs de cette assemblée
mais je ne crois pas que la chasse en
france se limite à la somme et je ne
crois pas non plus qu'au plan politique
la chasse se limite à l'ump je veux dire
par là que je suis un peu marri de voir
que la chasse en france est représentée
par une seule formation politique pour
laquelle j'ai le plus grand respect même
si je la combat par un seul département
pour qui j'ai même de l'affection
briques qui ne représente pas notre pays
et que ça va beaucoup plus loin
même dans les instances qui représente
la chasse mais là c'est un autre débat
nous socialistes apporteront
certainement après des discussions
correspondantes aux différents articles
notre soutien à ce texte qui malgré tout
va dans le bon sens
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant au président yvon collin pour
le rds
une seule présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues passé après jean
louis carrère est un plaidoyer aussi
vibrant mais bryant n'est pas chose
aisée néanmoins nous abordons l'examen
du temps est très attendu même de la
proposition de loi visant à moderniser
le droit de la chasse déposée par notre
excellent collègue pierre martin 15 mars
2010 un texte qui s'ajoute ça a été dit
et répété sans lois successives adopter
sur ce thème depuis 2000 mais un texte
indispensable car n'oublions pas que la
chasse est plus qu'un simple loisir
c'est une activité qui participe
pleinement à l'identité de notre
territoire et plus particulièrement
aussi il faut le dire au dynamisme de
nombreuses zones rurales et la france ce
n'est pas le cas de tous les pays
d'ailleurs permis de chasse populaire
populaire dans le sens où elle est
ouverte à tous ceux qui souhaitent la
pratique et sous réserve bien sûr un
permis bien entendu c'est en effet une
tradition de notre pays d'avoir une
chasse démocratique faut-il le rappeler
conquêtes de la révolution française
accessible à tous loisirs sportives
pratique ancestrale
la chasse est donc encore bien plus
aujourd'hui
en effet depuis la prise de conscience
collective de la nécessité de préserver
l'environnement et respecter la nature
la chasse est investi de plus en plus
concrètement d'une mission de gestion de
la biodiversité ce qui lui impose des
responsabilités dans le domaine de la
gestion des habitats de la régulation
des espèces et in fine et de la
protection des écosystèmes
soucieux de répondre aux nouvelles
préoccupations de la société les
chasseurs qui sont des gens intelligents
ont bien compris et très bien accepté
cette nouvelle mission
j'ajouterai que delà des effets concrets
sur l' équilibre écologique cette
vocation reconnu maintenant depuis
plusieurs années contribue à apaiser les
tensions avec ceux qui s'opposent à la
chasse en tout cas nous l'espérons
il me semble en effet important que la
chasse ne soient pas stigmatisés comme
les défenseurs de la cause animale ne
doit pas l'être non plus d'ailleurs
même la ministre mes chers collègues si
la chasse a su s'adapter aux nouvelles
attentes et aux nouveaux besoins de la
société
si la chasse a su s'insérer dans les
paysages parfois transformer son cadre
législatif n'est pas encore totalement
adapté à ses nouvelles missions
pourtant pourtant comme je le dis au
début de mon propos le législateur s'est
régulièrement pencher sur la question de
la chasse en particulier depuis 2003
depuis l'adaptation des statuts types
des fédérations de chasseurs auxquels la
loi du 26 juillet 2000 avait confié des
responsabilités d'intérêt général sont
soumises lors de l'examen de la loi du
23 février 2005 relative au
développement des territoires ruraux
nous avons une nouvelle fois réaffirmé
le rôle et la place des chasseurs en
précisant qu'il participait au
développement des activités économiques
écologiques dans les milieux naturels
notamment dans les territoires à
caractère rural c'était une étape une
étape importante contribuant à faire
poser un nouveau regard sur les
chasseurs on a peut-être parfois besoin
de changer le regard qu'on porte sur nos
chasseurs en fait nous avons ajouté une
nouvelle pierre à l'édifice avec
l'adoption fin 2008 de la loi pour la
simplification et l'amélioration de la
chasse il s'agissait notamment de
renforcer la portée juridique du plan de
schéma départemental de gestion
cynégétique et le tarn-et-garonne
échanges suis particulièrement fier a
été le premier département à conclure ce
schéma en 2006 nous étions un précurseur
et moi même et mon collègue jean michel
bayet en sommes très fiers
il s'agissait aussi d'encourager la
pratique de la chasse notamment auprès
des jeunes car l'activité qu'on ait une
décrue de ses effectifs a été dit déjà
préjudiciable dans certaines zones à la
maîtrise la prolifération du gibier nous
avons d'autre part vu la gouvernance de
la chasse en permettant notamment aux
fédérations nationales et aux
fédérations départementales d'être
éligible à l'agrément au pti
de la protection de la nature je
n'oublie pas de dire que nous avions
également alléger les procédures
administratives ce qui était important
car la chasse est une activité de
proximité et qui a besoin de souplesse
dans son fonctionnement au quotidien
aujourd'hui si la présente proposition
de loi est adoptée elle le sera pas nous
allons franchir une nouvelle étape
législative tant attendu par les
fédérations de chasseurs le texte vise
d'une part à poursuivre le mouvement de
simplification que je viens d'exposer et
d'autre part de renforcer encore et
encore le rôle des chasseurs dans la
préservation de la biodiversité et
personnellement je m'en réjouis
je ne vous cacherai pas que la
fédération départementale des chasseurs
du tarn et garonne qui se réunit très
récemment dans une excellente ambiance
d'ailleurs approuvent cette démarche
sénatoriales qu'elle préfère à la
soudaine initiative des députés qualité
ce qui a été déjà soulignée par notre
collègue car c'est d'ailleurs la
position des quatre parlementaires nomme
de mon département et ce au delà des
clivages partisans
il existe en effet un consensus est
large sur la proposition de loi de notre
collègue martin vous l'avez souligné mon
cher collègue rapporteur elle est le
fruit d'une véritable concertation entre
les principaux acteurs de la chasse la
fédération nationale des chasseurs bien
sûr l'office national de la chasse et de
la faune sauvage mais aussi les
associations communales de chasse
agréées les ak je suis pour ma part
satisfait de voir que si la commission
de l'économie président et avec talent
par notre collègue jean paul emorine à
amender la plupart des articles elle a
conservé le fond des dispositifs et
respecter c'est le plus important
l'esprit du texte c'est pourquoi je vous
indique d'ores et déjà que l'ensemble
des membres du rdse voteront la
proposition de loi l'article premier
reconnaît la compétence des fédérations
départementales de chasseurs en matière
d'information et d'éducation au
développement durable en matière de
connaissance et de préservation de la
faune sauvage c'est important c'était
déjà d'ailleurs le cas c'est déjà le cas
la pêche et il serait donc logique qu'il
était logique de le faire également pour
la chasse l'article 2 consiste à
introduire une disposition fiscale non
discriminatoires pour pouvoir continuer
à entretenir les zones humides les zones
entretenue par les chasseurs étant des
zones privilégiées pour tout les espaces
les espèces aviaires chassables non
chassable cette mesure 1 coûteuse pour
les temps il faut le souligner qu'il ya
une mesure peu coûteuses pour l'état
madame la ministre se rassemblent
d'accord c'est ce qui est encore dans la
perspective de la préservation de la
biodiversité dans l'esprit de l'article
1er un troisième article vise à
moderniser le code de l'environnement
précisant que la chasse peut contribuer
à une gestion équilibrée de la
biodiversité s'est dit si l'efficacité
et dont l'utilité dé sa soeur qui est
reconnu ceci est important également
je pense que l'article 4 et non sous la
bonne formule pour mettre en place un
outil juridique destinée à traiter des
espaces nom ou sous chasse et où
prolifèrent certaines espèces au
détriment des récoltes et d'autres
espèces jean louis carrère l'a encore
rappelé bien sûr la mesure est à mon
sens équilibré car les respecte le droit
à l'opposition cynégétique
quant aux articles 5 et 6 qui ont pour
objet d'une part de promouvoir
l'intercommunalité cynégétique d'autre
part d'assouplir les modalités
d'adhésion à une ak elle était très
attendue il faut en effet créé les
conditions de la continuité de la
gestion cynégétique qui pourrait être à
terme perturbé par la désertification
rurale
en fait la proposition de loi apporte
une réponse à l'ambiguïté créé par la
rédaction du dispositif de diminution du
coût du permis pour les jeunes chasseurs
issus la loi du 31 décembre 2008
notamment l'article l 223 21 du code de
l'environnement a conduit à une
déperdition importante de personnes qui
ont réussi l'examen mais qui n'ont pas
validé leur câble il fallait remédier à
cette difficulté ce sera fait grâce à
l'article 7 judicieusement complété lors
de son examen en commission mais chers
collègues en terminant sur le président
toutes ces mesures il n'est pas inutile
de le répéter vont dans le bon sens elle
consacre le rôle des chasseurs en tant
que connaisseur
on le rappelle jamais à ses fins
connaisseurs d'ailleurs mais aussi
protecteur de la nature comme je
l'indiquais le conseil de l'europe en
la chasse est et il est essentiel à la
préservation de la biodiversité à
l'équipe des espaces ruraux et
j'ajouterais que dans un monde qui
s'urbanise essais déshumanise un peu
trop à mon sens les chasseurs sont aussi
les gardiens de l'identité des
territoires menacés
il faut donc ne pas les décourager mais
plutôt les encourager dans le respect
naturellement des convictions des uns et
des autres c'est bien le sens de cette
proposition de loi qui reste dans
l'esprit de la très célèbre loi
verdeille que tous les sénateurs
radicaux de gauche et l'ensemble du rdse
dans sa diversité à prouver je vous
remercie de votre attention
merci monsieur le président je note la
ponctualité
monsieur gérard le cas maintenant la
parole pour le crc spg
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues me semble utile de
dire en propos liminaire que la chasse
est un sujet et si controversé que
parfois nous sommes amenés à penser que
moins on en parle mieux hausse porte le
sujet réveille chaque fois les passions
des amoureux de la chasse comme celle
des anti chasse de tout poil toujours
prêt à nous plus mais la proposition de
loi de notre collègue pierre martin
président du groupe chasse et pêche au
sénat s'inscrit dans un paysage plutôt
apaisé ce qui ne signifie pas qu'il soit
exempt de danger
l'article premier inscrit dans la loi
les missions d'information et
d'éducation au développement durable en
matière de connaissance et de
préservation de la faune sauvage et de
ses habitats ainsi qu'en matière de
gestion de la biodiversité
ces missions conduites par les
fédérations départementales sont réelles
et ne demande qu'à croître au delà de la
formation au permis de chasser des
interventions auprès des scolaires des
conventions et le monde agricole
ce sont des millions
de concitoyens qui utilisent la nature
dans le cadre de leurs loisirs tout en
ignorant ce qu'elle recèle en matière de
biodiversité de la faune et de la flore
sans prétention et avec d'autres
organisations
les fédérations de chasseurs sont
particulièrement performantes pour le
volet diversité faunistique et
l'entretien des milieux où vit la faune
sauvage qui mieux qu'un technicien
cynégétique pourra vous expliquer
quelles espèces vivent cachés dans la
nature quelles sont leurs moeurs leurs
quels indices de présence permettent de
les détecter au même type k1 nicollin
pour les champignons qu'à un
ornithologue pour les oiseaux leur rôle
est essentiel pour une bonne
connaissance et une protection
intelligente des milieux naturels
l'article 3 vient compléter ses missions
par la reconnaissance du rôle de la
chasse en matière de gestion équilibrée
des écosystèmes et de la biodiversité
tout se tient dans le mot équilibre et
aucun chasseur n'a intérêt à
déséquilibrer une espèce à la faveur
d'une autre un espace au détriment d'un
autre
à ce titre l'equilibre agro sylvo
cynégétique illustre bien ce qui doit
être fait pour permettre à chacun des
chasseurs agriculteurs et forestier de
cohabiter en bonne intelligence
le milieu naturel est constamment
façonnés par l'homme par les pratiques
agricoles et forestières modifié par
l'évolution de l'urbanisme restructuré
par les différents modes de propriété
les chasseurs doivent donc à la fois
s'adapter à ces évolutions et collaborer
avec des divers différents acteurs pour
préserver la biodiversité et la
possibilité de pratiquer leur loisir
favori chacun de st les principaux
dégâts causés à la biodiversité ne sont
pas liées à la chasse les pesticides les
broyages certaines pratiques culturales
la myxomatose ont tué bien plus que la
chasse elle même quant aux migrateurs
ils sont souvent victimes des conditions
climatiques et de la modification par
l'homme de biotope qui leur était
favorable
cette reconnaissance de la chasse comme
instrument efficace de gestion de la
biodiversité encouragera poursuivre les
multiples actions déjà engagées dans les
zones humides pour les différents
biotopes
les les cultures à gibier les jachères
fleuries l'article 4 précise les
responsabilités des différents
propriétaires des zones ont chassé aux
souches ac qui abrite parfois des
populations conséquente de sangliers ces
derniers provoquent des dégâts
importants et coûteux sur des
territoires voisins qui sont chassés
il n'est pas inutile de rappeler que ce
sont les chasseurs via leur fédération
qui paye les dégâts de gibier aux
agriculteurs dont les cultures sont
parfois ravagé les articles 5 et 6
concernent les associations communales
de chasse agréées afin d'une part de
leur permettre de se regrouper en
association intercommunale de chasse
agréée et d'autre part d'assouplir les
modalités d'adhésion
ces deux articles témoigne des
difficultés que rencontre le monde de la
chasse dont les effectifs se réduisent
serons-nous suffisamment nombreux demain
pour maintenir les équilibres de la
biodiversité pour financer les dégâts de
gibier pour réguler les nuisibles
une vraie question un vrai problème pour
demain qui ne doit réjouir personne dans
la mesure où tout ce qui se fait
naturellement aujourd'hui par les
chasseurs pourrait être à la charge de
la société demain donc sur notre feuille
d'impôts enfin l'article 7 précise des
conditions d'attribution de la
diminution de moitié des redevances à
régler par des chasseurs prenant leur
premier permis cet article permet
d'évoquer le manque d'engouement des
nouvelles générations pour la chasse
sans aucun doute faudra-t-il trouver
d'autres moyens pour sensibiliser les
jeunes à la faveur de ce sport loisir
qui en vaut bien d'autres
la chasse en france aura certainement
toujours a imaginé et créé pour assurer
son avenir
la fonte des effectifs de chasseurs est
un danger réel
le rapport qu'elle a vis-à-vis de la
société évoluera-t-il en sa faveur
ou le contraire c'est donc dès
aujourd'hui qu'il nous faut anticiper ce
que sera la chasse de demain nous avons
pour l'instant la force du nombre
et celle de l'ancrage populaire au sein
de nos collectivités locales ce texte
comporte notamment le rôle de la chasse
à la faveur de la biodiversité et de
l'environnement
c'est dans cette voie qu'il faut
poursuivre en maintenant les équilibres
ont réintroduisant des sous
naturel et résistante pour le petit
gibier en consacrant encore davantage de
temps et de moyens à l'entretien des
espaces naturels
une nature morte c'est très beau sur un
tableau mais une nature vivante dans une
ruralité vivante est encore plus beau le
groupe crc spg votre à la proposition de
loi qui vise à moderniser la chasse il
reste vigilant avec son réseau d'élus
locaux pour que la chasse populaire
continue d'être accessible et attractif
pour tous je vous remercie
nous quittons l'hémicycle du sénat merci
à vous d'avoir suivi cette séance pour
la revoir notre site internet
publicsenat.fr prochain rendez vous avec
à l'actualité politique et parlementaire
c'est à 19h avec michel grossiord merci
de votre fidélité très belle journée à
tous